elon musk
made this point another very important
figure from very different sectors
of society elon musk just came out he
said i can't emphasize this enough there
are not enough people
musk said this to the wall street
journal and i think one of the biggest
risks to civil civilization is the low
birth rate and the rapidly declining
birth rate and yet so many people
including smart people think that there
are too many people in the world and
think that the population is growing out
of control it's completely the opposite
please look at the numbers if people
don't have more children civilization is
going to crumble mark my words he's
absolutely right we've had a dying
population in this country for decades
and it's recently gotten a lot worse and
that's true throughout the civilized
west it's just collapsing and
the way that the ruling class tries to
prop up the civilization is just by
importing a ton of foreigners and that's
causing a lot of problems too huge
problems of assimilation this is the
largest movement of people in the
history of the world
and you're seeing the problems with that
all around you
but you can't do that forever you can't
just
replace all the people because they're
dying and getting old and not having any
children and then expect to have the
exact same civilization it's not going
to work
you need
you need to have kids this is a major
major issue
and what you will hear from people and
this is a perfectly legit concern
is
well the not legit concern you're going
to hear is how dare you i want to go
work at the widget factory and you can't
tell me what to do and
who are you to say this and uh maybe
it's not right for me no i who am i to
say this i don't know i'm a person with
semi-functioning faculties of reason and
a moral conscience in a historical sense
and we actually can make public
statements about the way people behave
that's what society is that's what
politics is so yes we can we can say
it's better to do this than to do that
people should do this they shouldn't do
that we should discourage good things
and or we should encourage good things
we should discourage bad things but the
legit the legit concern is
kids are expensive kids are expensive
wages have completely stagnated in some
cases they've declined
the working class has gotten absolutely
crushed relative to the ruling class
everyone is swimming in mountains of
debt
the sexual revolution has destroyed the
relationship between men and women
there are now very few inducements to
marriage the supreme court completely
redefined marriage that didn't help
things either and so it's difficult
it's difficult and it's expensive and we
don't have the resources to do it
yes that's true
it is true if we want to have a society
that produces more kids then we're going
to have to have less stuff
you're not going to be able to buy as
much nice stuff or go to as many nice
restaurants or get as much delicious
avocado toast or drink these expensive
fruity seltzer drinks that i like so
much that i usually just pill for from
the daily wire you're not going to be
able to have as many luxuries if you
have kids you're right but that's part
of what pope francis is saying
he's saying it is selfish to prioritize
your own immediate pleasures over having
a child so yeah you will have to deal
with that and there is there is a
criticism of conservatives the criticism
is this you conservatives you're talking
all about family values and having lots
of kids and and rebuilding the
civilization but you don't want to
support anybody with any money you're
stingy you're greedy conservatives now
this is mostly a canard
conservatives for instance give more
money to charity than liberals do and
it's not even close even the new york
times has even admitted this
but
there there has been a sense on the
right
that we don't support social programs
we don't support welfare certainly not
at the federal level there's been a
little bit of this
ein rand fend for yourself pull yourself
up by your bootstraps ideology on the
right that is shallow and doesn't work
in every situation
so let me correct the record
because i think that there is a
caricature of what it meant to be a
republican in the 80s and i don't think
that's really
what it means to be a republican now
i
would fully support
a
government program with some
stipulations you'd obviously need
safeguards i would 100 support a
government program that pays married
couples to have kids
100
of course i would i am so excited to
talk about a brand new sponsor to the
show that sponsor this is a sponsor that
i have wanted on this show for years at
this point i frankly i kind of feel like
i made it
i'm talking about birch gold birch gold
a wonderful company and a really
important one right now because
inflation is at 40-year highs and it is
here to stay why well here's the
government's dirty little secret the
government
wants inflation they want inflation
because right now inflation rates are
higher than the interest on treasury
bonds which means that with every day
that passes the government owes less on
its mountain of debt imagine if you had
a negative interest rate on your
mortgage would you be in any hurry to
pay that off i don't think so so your
pain is their game protect your savings
now do it with
gold from birch gold wonderful hedge
against inflation the government is
sabotaging the value of the u.s dollar
so allow birch gold to help you convert
an eligible ira or 401k into an ira
backed by real gold that is peace of
mind
with thousands of satisfied customers an
a plus rating for the better business
bureau you can trust birch gold to
protect your savings text knolls k wles
to 9898
to get a free info kit on holding gold
in a tax sheltered account
then call birch and protect your
hard-earned savings text knowles
k-w-l-e-s to 98-98-98
that's k-n-w-l-e-s text it get your free
info kit right now conservatives have
tried to
split the baby on this issue in recent
years and so they'll say well we'll give
you a child tax credit well will allow
you to deduct certain things from your
taxes and we'll allow you to file in
this way and will allow you to save
money in this way for college or then
it hasn't worked
so it's easy for conservatives to get
discouraged and say well then nothing's
going to work if we use our politics but
it might just be that we haven't done
enough or we haven't done the right
things because hungary for instance and
to a lesser degree russia have taken
more drastic measures to redir reduce
the
the or to reverse the declining
population
and it's worked it totally in hungary it
totally worked you finally saw an uptick
again in the population and russia if
you believe russia's numbers seems to
have seen the same sort of thing
you need safeguards you need but you
can't
you can't have a civilization if you
don't have any people
okay you can't have a country without
people
and you can't
endlessly prop up a country by
ignoring national borders ignoring
immigration law completely upending your
culture that's not going to work either
encouraging sterility and and
promiscuity you're not going to have a
civilization that way at a certain point
you've got to defend those bedrock
institutions the foundational
institution is marriage is the family
and you've got to have people that's
your main resource as a country and i
think conservatives are getting woke
not in the leftist sense of woke but
they're just kind of waking up to the
problems of some failed policy and
they're recognizing if we don't have
people we're not going to have a country
and they're moving in that direction
you're blake masters talking about this
kind of stuff he's running for senate in
arizona you hear jd vance he's running
for senate in ohio you hear a lot of the
national conservatives talking about
this a lot of the integralist
conservatives talking about this you
hear some humble podcasters such as
myself talking about this this is
the future
all right and when elon musk
and
pope francis
and
jd vance all agree on a policy let's do
it let's go for it okay i'm so glad you
liked that clip welcome to my humble
abode
welcome to the inner sanctum
if you want more insight like this if
you want more special glimpses into
what's going on in my mind
in my home then i would strongly
recommend you
ring that bell
subscribe get those notifications head
on over to apple podcast but if i stitch
your google play wherever you get your
audio podcast
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]